Speaker 1: Early voting has broken records
already two weeks before Election Day. But I
have to tell you, it is not obvious to me what
this means. So let's start with the news and
then we'll work backwards. CBS reporting early
voting turnout breaking records two weeks before
Election Day with seven I'm sorry, with 15 days
to go to Election Day. Early voting is underway
in 34 states and D.C. More than seven and a half
million people have already voted either in person
or by mail. Some states have already smashed early
voting records set in the presidential election of
2020, but voting has not been without incident.
We talked about the people with guns and tactical
gear in Arizona, etc., etc., etc.. The most
important question about this early voting record,
and we were talking about this I was talking
about this in another context recently, is
which side is voting in record numbers? And is
that a signal about what might happen in this
election? Or are both sides just voting in record
numbers? And maybe the most important question is
whether the early voting records are related to
enthusiasm or it's merely that more people are
voting early and fewer people will vote on the day
of, but that it doesn't actually represent more
enthusiasm for participating in this particular
election. Is it not reflective of higher overall
turnout? And I don't think we have that answer
yet. And the thought process is as follows
In 2020, many states in the context of the COVID
pandemic, expanded early and mail in voting.
Many people took advantage of that, but many
did not. It was the first time for some of those
expansions in many states. Now that it is more
known, we may simply be seeing a shift from people
waiting to vote on Election Day to choosing
to vote early, either in person or by mail.
If that is the case, it doesn't necessarily mean
voter turnout will be particularly high. No matter
what you think is going on. And no matter what is
going on. Just vote. Just vote. The headline may
be great news, potentially a pacifier. The most
important takeaway is no matter when you vote,
your vote matters. And we want everyone to
show up and vote. Let's have a representative
democracy that is as representative of
as high a percentage of the population
as possible. And that means every single one of
us should vote. Reminder, reminder, reminder.
Our YouTube channel has a million and a half
subscribers, but we had 4.3 million people
watch our videos last month. This leaves
nearly 3 million people who are watching
the content but aren't subscribed. I heard after
I mentioned this earlier this week from a dozen
or so people who said, you know, David, I watch
all your clips. I'm not a subscriber on YouTube
because YouTube just feeds me the clips anyway.
And I understand that. Help us by hitting the
subscribe button on YouTube. It's totally free.
It's one of the most important signals to YouTube.
Hey, promote this guy's content more.
It costs nothing. And there's almost 3
million of you out there who can do this for
us. YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer, a listener,
an audience supported program. And I would
love for you to sign up and show your support
at Join. Pacman NBC.com This is the membership
program, the much discussed and much maligned.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Indeed. Indeed. Alex, thank you. We
do a daily bonus show and offer a commercial free
audio and video stream to all of our members every
single day. Sign up at join Packman dot com. We're
down to the wire on election 22. You can use the
coupon code. Big voting 22, big voting 22 to get
a healthy discount off of the cost of a membership